fue el complejo metalúrgico más grande
de América del Sur durante casi un siglo
la mayoría de los minerales del
continente pasaban por la oroya antes de
la quiebra de la empresa mineram en 2009
para ver la chimenea de la fábrica
humeando nuevamente los ex trabajadores
compraron la empresa hace unos meses
[Música]
esta noticia fue bien recibida por la
mayoría de los habitantes
[Música]
nosotros como trabajadores Hemos salido
fuera de acá del Oro allá para buscar
una buena versión para nuestros hijos en
las cuales ahorita si se activa la
empresa vamos a tener más posibilidades
de trabajo y más Progreso para el
horario pero más allá de estas
esperanzas de recuperación económica hay
una amenaza reconocida para los
habitantes en 2011 la oroya fue la
segunda ciudad más contaminada del mundo
así algunos todavía se niegan a creerlo
la contaminación
si fuera contaminación todo no
estaríamos contamina ahorita pues
seríamos con eso mongolitos en aquella
época el procesamiento del cobre el
plomo y El zinc la liberación de metales
pesados en el aire lo que dejó algunos
habitantes con malos recuerdos recuerdo
que el río era muy contaminado Bueno yo
recuerdo que a veces visitaba por las
casas de los alrededores y el momento de
subir de caminar No podía me asfixiaba
entonces esa sensación de que me picaba
la nariz la garganta no podía los ojos
se me irritaba me ardían humo
contaminado con plomo dióxido de azufre
y Arsénico con concentraciones 10 a 15
veces superiores a los umbrales
recomendados como ves todo está blanco
está quemado debido al Arsénico Por
ejemplo si se quiere hacer agricultura
en los productos que salen van a salir
con o metales pesados cadmio plomo
Arsénico y obviamente eso no es viable
para el consumo humano
este abogado Acompaña a 80 demandantes
ante la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos acusan al Estado peruano de
dejar que la empresa contaminara al
retrasar los plazos para cumplir con las
normas ambientales Esperamos que esa
sentencia pueda salir en junio Julio o a
más tardar en octubre siendo optimistas
los demandantes como Pablo exigen
reparación
acá les voy a presentar mis documentos
de Amparo sobre los análisis que se ha
realizado
sobre plomo en sangre Arsénico cadmio
como el 99% de los niños del barrio su
hija tenía en 2009 un nivel de plomo en
la sangre que superaba lo normal
plomo en sangre
24.34
micras por decilitro de plomo en Sangre
y recomendaciones
retiro de la Fuente de exposición no
podemos retirar porque acá es nuestra
vivencia la pareja también solicita al
Estado una atención médica correcta
Pablo y digna viven desde hace 20 años
frente a la fábrica estos días empezó a
doler los dedos los índices del dedos de
los dos manos el pulmón bastante los
huesos también no a nosotros nos han
hecho una evaluación de huesos grandes
huesos medianos
de la existencia de plomo en nuestros
huesos la respuesta de esto le va a dar
es en sopas
a 175 kilómetros en la capital
recuerda sus 30 años de ejercicio en la
olla fue uno de los primeros en advertir
sobre los peligros de los metales
pesados por ejemplo retrasos en el
desarrollo de los niños pero los
síntomas del envenenamiento por plomo a
menudo pasan desapercibidos inicialmente
y solo aparecen años después se puede
quedar hasta 20 o 30 años dentro de los
huesos por ejemplo hasta una simple
gripe que provoca fiebre y todo estimule
al sistema óseo para que de ahí empiece
a salir no los depósitos de plomo
para escapar de ese riesgo cientos de
habitantes abandonaron la olla en la
década del 2000 algunos de ellos se
instalaron en los barrios pobres de Lima
en la otra también está mi hijita
su piernitas lleno de heridita era como
una niña de 10 a 9 años había niños
también igualito que no crecían por la
contaminación señorita su hija murió
debido a una enfermedad a la edad de 17
años Mercedes atribuyó la muerte a la
contaminación de la empresa
estas acusaciones en los medios locales
le han valido amenazas la gente de mi
pueblo de la oroya hasta me escupían me
empujaban me decían traidora por todas
esas amenazas señorita yo salgo de la
olla yo extraño mi oroya señorita
extraño bastante
en la oroya la fundición sigue cerrada
los compradores aseguran que cumplirán
con las normas ambientales sin haber
obtenido por el momento las
autorizaciones necesarias para la
reanudación de la actividad
[Música]